economía en directo a América ya está
con nosotros en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos con
la noticia de los mercados bursátiles en
el mundo la nueva subida en los tipos de
interés por parte de la reserva Federal
en Estados Unidos esto estremece el
mundo entero sin duda alguna y es una de
las noticias más seguidas por los
inversionistas y economistas la fe subió
nuevamente en 25 puntos básicos en las
tasas de interés de referencia y
advirtió también que su ciclo de
endurecimiento monetario podría
continuar a lo largo de este año El
Banco Central de Estados Unidos si tú
ahora el precio del dinero entre el
4,75% y el 5% pero elimina del
comunicado la referencia a más aumentos
sucesivos de los tipos de interés más
altos en desde el año 2007 se trata
también de la segunda subida de un
cuarto de punto como parte de sus
decisiones que comenzaron justo hace un
año en marzo del 2022 la Fed acepta que
los recientes acontecimientos pueden
establecer las condiciones crediticias
para las familias en el comunicado del
comité cambian la forma en que el banco
se refiere a los próximos movimientos de
la política monetaria antes agregaban
que harían falta aumento sucesivos de
los tipos de interés ahora excluyen esto
y muchos creen que deja la puerta
abierta a pausar esta subida de los
tipos de interés Pese a que muchos
economistas e inversionistas esperaban
la subida
Hablamos de una de las decisiones más
difíciles de la Fed en los últimos años
eso tomando en cuenta los temores del
sector bancario tras la quiebra de
varias instituciones en los últimos días
escuchamos parte del discurso que daba
Jean Paul
d creemos sin embargo que los
acontecimientos ocurridos en el sistema
bancario durante Las dos últimas semanas
probablemente den lugar a un
endurecimiento de las condiciones
crediticias para los hogares Y las
empresas es demasiado pronto para
determinar el alcance de estos efectos y
por tanto para saber cómo debería
responder la política monetaria Jorge
después de estas decisiones Cómo se
comportaron los mercados hoy los
principales indicadores bursátiles bueno
el que sufrió más pérdidas fue Wall
Street que terminó con fuertes caídas
después de este discurso de Powell que
dijo En una conferencia de prensa que
los funcionarios seguían empeñados en
luchar contra la inflación en Europa
hubo tendencia alcista previo a la
decisión de la reserva federal y en
América Latina la bolsa de Sao Paulo
retrocedió tras la nueva subida de los
tipos de interés en Estados Unidos
continuamos ahora hablando pues
justamente de esas turbulencias
bancarias en Estados Unidos que Tal
parece que continúan bueno cualquiera
que sea el plan para salvar al último
banco el First Republic desde ya sus
accionistas salen perdiendo según los
analistas de Wall Street el valor
contable tangible del banco está muy por
encima del valor nominal lo que crea un
déficit de capital de hasta 13.500
millones de dólares una suma que puede
ayudar a explicar porque aún nadie
compra este banco las acciones que
cotizaban a más de 120 dólares a
principios de mes cayeron hasta los
13,33 dólares luego de que los
dirigentes de Bank acordaran renunciar a
las primas del 2023 incluso Morgan
Stanley considera que las acciones de
este banco podrían llegar a valer
solamente un dólar por acción su
análisis en su análisis del escenario
bajista nuevamente la secretaria del
tesoro de Estados Unidos se refirió a
esta situación en el sistema bancario
nuestra máxima prioridad es proteger la
salud de la economía estadounidense hace
dos semanas nos enteramos de problemas
en dos bancos que Podrían haber tenido
un impacto significativo en el sistema
bancario y la economía estadounidense
en los días siguientes el tesoro trabajó
con la reserva Federal para tomar
medidas de cumplimiento decisivas para
fortalecer la confianza en el sistema
bancario estadounidense tomamos medidas
para proteger a todos los usuarios de
las dos instituciones fallidas y
proporcionar liquidez adicional a los
bancos
Esto fue diseñado para mitigar los
riesgos para el sistema bancario
Jorge de Estados Unidos pasamos a
Argentina allí presentaron los datos
económicos del cuarto trimestre da un
poco de susto ver que lo que reportan
desde Argentina Qué dijeron Bueno hay
dos cifras importantes ese país acumuló
el año pasado un avance del 5,2% del
producto interno bruto muy por debajo
del repunte del y registró en el cuarto
trimestre del 2022 una contracción del
1,5% con respecto al tercer trimestre de
los 17 sectores que conforman el pib
argentino en 16 de ellos se observó
mejora de la actividad durante 2022
Aunque mucho menor que los reportado en
2021 entre estos sectores destacaron la
construcción la industria y el comercio
el único sector que registró una
contracción de actividad en el 2022 fue
de la agricultura y ganadería con una
caída del
4,1%. hoy se conoció también que los
organismos del Estado argentino que
cuentan con bonos en dólares deberán
vender sus títulos para que el gobierno
pueda contener esta subida paralela del
dólar contra los pesos argentinos que
responden a la falta de reservas en ese
país los tipos de cambios paralelos
reflejan esos desequilibrios
macroeconómicos de Argentina en un
contexto de endeudamiento alta inflación
y fuertes restricciones al acceso al
mercado cambiario oficial
ya una escasez de dólares que hay en
Argentina Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía a
continuación en directo a América ya
viene el debate
[Música]